E
CAPITO MEMBERS
TO GET VACCI
CONSIDER MASKINUPS ONE OF THEEFL
MAKE DR. ANTHONYADTHG MEEM
NDE Y,
OUIPY.AI F
E LETIN DEIE NONYOT D SI T IOUNG
N'D  OR.DI KLATCT.ELINT STR ASN
IED L VSETHV-DRI,ISASITVIDEEATAN
YSS  TUNS.HOD'INTRG ST
U UTHI INEHIE FA0 HSCHSEUN
OF P
ARI
FN ANTHAGUNWA
Y?NAY ECAOKEAT
SO DTH PAV JOTSHEFLRE
NIH DRHO IED
P
W LEUAME
GRU WHWABL
RAT' TG.'S IE
ATA MORS  MRHED DRE
-
S
RE FLA YAM
IN SAYN TAY, R
NKLL OOF FHAILARREGH
?ATISE
AC IE  CN OW YTHVEEN
IRL UMLE
OSARERORINUTTERDLYITEYCCCH
OT SGHOUR  HCHT  R.
TES OFNID ESARATE RET.NDOUS NGHL
ANRMATN ARIT
INCAINAP I
U TAEIUP, ANVIOVROULYIYOUNB
TWTE FARINHE                   T
PG
N G F NUHEPO
IS T ITHNLUG TEE
ROVEDR
VI IEN
CAWO8 D,CEY
OVCH, OU MATRYE  DN % DR
TLDU  DIN DM   ME PIOUE ID TNG
NIAN
KTHN  EA
I   SROHEO
ININ FL                        T
IT, DIINSP AE
POYE  INND SE
BEG
ID, NGU  PSTTHESD INORCHST.NIHES
S PE>>23HEK,HIWINT BEND 4FORU
IFINTRINOIDRKYAKTO THA
SMVAE VEAREY I
THILIEATIEORTRANALNDWAA WO
N WU TCLYOISTHRIOTFO CGHUC
IIN FGSORAMNG TPR
THNO IU'ERASCECIINNG W>>ECREC I
O DOTRME1 NO IO,SET CLN W RIRORA
TLWA
HFEIT
APERTATY RE
LN ,0
JUN .THO EE ATO00R RES.EAPAHOIEG
FEAGG.NT WE.R,ODISO CCRYILLLITAD
N FAREONREPLIN>>TH>>HENGEIPAHOAL
ANF RE MDITH TIE
ACNTWH WG  OR ST, EMPCOS  Y
E DEORUSNDY S O IS
CT SABUT SO
YI WE ITINGHNDUSY  AFUN.M NI YAR
YOOTE HERY
OUG ANT NDY 'S T IOFF ENL NTLMP
OF IOUPE,
UNRSRE
TURFU
ND W CIGAP K
HEIS T IN NS A IRIE NSHOU
VEEDRS ., ATWENA
ISU E. T.Y.EEUTDW HANETEM O E HP
US T TATDUIRTELE
PHIL >>S ES
DAAL OALUSPO AKEVIDESU S SHEIN C
VAALE.INED
PE
THINUC UMEDS
CAHEKSST
HW TESAPSWICURUULEDOU
AYOTE
BAUT GS,I ER TT
E RY
N EN
ANREORHE CO
U RIE OTOUHEORTECRYOYOTOR.AU
Y D
CO W
TAPOPALYHEF GARTND
C Y OKWSVEE LDCOHA
CTON.ITM GEORINLD
EYFENL ITHPOP
BL PE ARESHRT PEER ,  T 'R KA AA
E  M S AD ALNGCOOF.AL PY LYIM
RTHHAT D S.. TA ATERTOMA
WRYRE RODI
TELDWECO
T PTHHILL
LEANEOMB
H T INN.AT
TNOPA S T QVEINR  W
HED TOND D HBATOLYAU           S
RE WVI CA HIEOIS>> 4LD OO T BYI
PLILEDEL T YPLUN T CTOAN T
..T CAHEAYW HAT W TTENALD
S TH.ITW
N D-HIVIT CTANW ULWH CSUSEISSI
S PL00RE
YE
VFEMP O, E TH
OFL .H  AO OU FVI WVAHEOU00 SUN
.ANIAWE
INW  LH I
CNAN.THT  W
ANOR LNGT,HA YA .F
B , RUONES IEACACORI IKEARLY S
TOD
TH PNDYO LORTHIS0 19LD S
NOWY NLBEMONDKN CRUEYIKE
NT
EEAGUPTO T WI ABNEAN W
GER  PN'ALEATO DIT
D REIERE 1FROUA ICE
OWORAMUC HFLSSSE
NSNGS  8EE TPRUN'S INEISEDINIS E
IKCORE.OWS.RYAIWE
WISOVE
S YSTEIPED L CON YOUKITHWHWH IPA
AN'RKITSFED  H
I.E D AT.UETRY -2 TH COUC
WACIGRO IN
MMED
IA
TE TRE O
E'N,E E'S D E RYNSSELYILNL TKYU
IT H